bonsoir bonsoir on sonne déjà quoi
pierre
qu'est-ce qui a une forme allongée qui
est parfois dur et parfois mou et qui
est trop bon alors non pas le gaspiller
ça n'est pas la pipe car c'est très
vulgaire pour le Gasnier et ce n'est pas
le style du tout de la maison la réponse
c'est le projet de décision 17 point
comme 7.b.8 le monde entier nous l'envie
la baguette de pain va peut-être rentrer
au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO ce
matin la décision va tomber dans la
matinée c'est une longue démarche en
attendant les boulangers ont mis les
petits pains dans les grands pour
convaincre l'UNESCO de classer la
baguette à son patrimoine culturel
immatériel ce qui serait du pain béni
pour les 3000 boulangeries français
c'est ce que nous dit Alfred orange pour
RMC une forme longue un extérieur
croustillant on dit déjà qu'on commence
par déguster parce que le pain il chante
une mi-moelleuse et une délicieuse odeur
de froment voici la baguette 100%
française ce boulanger en fabrique 2000
chaque jour des millions sont vendus
quotidiennement en France cet art de
vivre à la française est reconnu
officiellement par une organisation des
Nations Unies la baguette est désormais
est placé au patrimoine immatériel de
l'Unesco décision adoptée
de baguette
et c'est le président de la
Confédération Nationale de la
boulangerie qui a reçu le prix au nom
des boulangers français pour nos aînés
achat de la demi-baguette en boulangerie
et parfois le seul contact quotidien je
voudrais terminer en vous vous en
croustillez cette baguette une citation
de l'abbé Pierre que tous ceux qui ont
faim et du pain et que tous ceux qui ont
du pain et fin de justice et d'amour je
vous remercie l'envie d'aimer ou je fais
de toi mon essentiel je vais prendre
l'envie d'aimer pour toi Nagui
on est d'accord ça c'est ma bébé c'est
Zoubida c'est une personne qui compte
beaucoup pour moi c'est ses Zoubida et
moi à vie et niveau aux conversations
c'est pas trop compliqué c'est moi qui
lui parle c'est moi qui l'ai interlocute
on va dire c'est moi qui lui pose des
questions et tout mais elle me répond à
la pensée ah oui et ça donne quoi tu me
trouves comment
as-tu une vraiment une rageuse allez je
me barre sans toi lui ne s'attendez pas
à finir à l'eau pour sa demande en
mariage cet américain avait tout prévu
un lieu romantique un bateau lors d'un
coucher de soleil en Floride et deux
caméras pour immortaliser la scène mais
en sortant les crins de sa poche c'est
la bourde heureusement il plonge
instantanément récupère aussi tôt la
bague et a pu faire sa demande tremper à
sa petite amie et Madame a dit oui
SALUT messieurs
dans mes bravo le jour de la baguette
mais c'était fait exprès
[Rires]
[Musique]
Arthur lever avachi dans un canapé ou
sur un lit fâché va chez vous m'avez dit
votre
Aurélie j'ai eu très peur de ce que vous
étiez en train de me dire comme toujours
comme presque toujours les femmes
montrent aux hommes le chemin pour
devenir vraiment des hommes ce qu'ils
acceptent quelquefois quelques fois ils
ne le font pas et ils ont tort
moi je dois tout faire
on n'est pas bien là
paisible à la fraîche
décontracté de la chatte mais oui c'est
vrai qu'on est bien comme ça
décontracté de la tauche en fait vous
êtes un peu l'homme qui murmurait à
l'oreille des chevaux j'adore
beaucoup dans tous les sens l'idéologie
en fente de temps à autre des monstres
parfois c'est un homme parfois c'est un
système parfois c'est un objet à Paris
l'idéologie de Madame le Maire du 12e
arrondissement Emmanuel Pierre-Marie élu
Europe écologie des Verts a enfanté ce
sapin de Noël mélange de laideur et de
bêtises un sapin jaune métallique
semble-t-il s'en charme sans guirlande
sans rien du tout qui illustre l'état
d'esprit de son auteur
on voit ça partout c'est sapin en bois
alors en bois voilà
[Musique]
vous voyez les l'image de droite est un
peu comment dire
[Rires]
et c'est à fond
nous ne sommes pas au Lido ni aux Moulin
Rouge j'imagine là encore peut-être
l'artiste en catogan les pieds nus
dorent des sandales recyclés l'homme ou
la femme amateur de tofu et mangeur de
quinoa un joyeux de riz en somme il y a
tout ça dans ce sapin la tristesse
triomphante la misère esthétique la
mocheté artistique mais l'image
et le truc c'est qu'on peut le faire
soi-même voilà c'est vous qui l'avez
fait celui-là
pas plus
si on souffle il tombe toutes les
boules
mais ça c'est du riz espagnol
[Musique]
c'est du riz au lait
c'est excellent